tja die beurteilung von absichten das
ist sicherlich das wichtigste in diesem
gefährlichen zeiten das war live aus
wien die pressekonferenz von raphael
gross sie dem chef der internationalen
atomenergie behörde im studio in bonn
hans dieter heumann der
sicherheitsexperte zwei dinge sind ja
angesprochen worden in sachen atom des
ist ab 1 die sicherheit beziehungsweise
die unsicherheit der atomanlagen in der
ukraine und es weiter sind die laufenden
gespräche rund um das atomprogramm des
iran und da deutet sich uns ganz
vorsichtig zu formulieren ja irgendwie
eine annäherung zwischen iran und den
usa an warum wäre das in dieser
situation jetzt besonders wichtig ja in
der tat
die interessante situation dass der
krieg in der ukraine möglicherweise
bewegung
möglicherweise bewegung in die
verhandlungen über das nuklearprogramm
der iraner bringt es könnte dazu führen
dass
neue gemeinsame interessen entdeckt
werden in diesen verhandlungen nämlich
das interesse
der westlichen teilnehmer dieser
verhandlung von den insgesamt sechs mit
dem iran nämlich dass iran öl
exportierende dass also die sanktionen
gelockert werden oder aufgehoben werden
was iran ermöglichen würde öl zu
exportieren was wiederum die augenblick
schwierige lage der
der nato länder und der europäischen
länder
angeht die darüber beraten ob sie öl und
gasimporte aus russland auch mit
blockieren werden also eine sehr
interessante verquickung die gemeinsame
interessen liegen auch darin
dass
mit ihrer dass diese bewegung in die
verhandlungen kommt allerdings darf man
nicht vergessen dass
die westliche position also die die
position von frankreich deutschland
england die die dort verhandelt haben
für aus osteuropa
dass die sanktionen gegen iran bisher
deshalb aufrecht erhalten würde um iran
davon abzubringen ihr uran weiter
anzureichern
was die zeit verkürzt in der der iran
eine wieder einen markt nuklearmacht
sein könnte also das ist jetzt wirklich
sehr kompliziert es könnte noch ein
faktor hinzu kommen zu diesen sechs
verhandlungspartner könnt ja auch
russland
und iran könnte auch zu dem schluss
kommen dass russland im augenblick hier
von russland dass ein engel ag enger
partner iran zwar im augenblick auch da
nicht viel zu erwarten ist noch ein
aspekt wenn die bewegung reinkommt sie
würden auch zeigen dass sanktionen
bisher gewirkt haben bei ihrer 1 war ja
war es tatsächlich so dass sie auch 2003
sich in die verhandlungen überhaupt nur
gegeben haben weil die sanktion damals
trifft ausschluss das hat damals auch
schon rolle hat die iranische wirtschaft
ja in große schwierigkeiten gebracht das
zeigt wie alles sowieso zusammenhängt in
diesem globalisierten zeiten aber jetzt
erst recht in dieser situation
andere spieler also der iran spielt
jetzt mit bei diesem ganzen problem man
sollte vielleicht noch mal sagen 2 5
millionen barrel öl pro tag könnten die
iraner liefern das wäre eine eine große
menge der andere große spieler der jetzt
offenbar tatsächlich
mitsprechen will ist china wir waren
vorher an dieser stelle unterbrochen
worden
vermittlungsangebot der chinesin warum
jetzt
also ich glaube das definierte den
letzten tagen wo sie so ein bisschen
würde tatsächlich sagen rumgeeiert haben
mit verschiedenen äußerungen sich dazu
entschlossen haben heute das anzubieten
also explizit dass anzubieten
wenn man die äußerung von heute vom
außenminister nimmt ist es wirklich ein
versuch westliche und russische
interessen auszubalancieren
er betont einerseits die notwendigkeit
dass die territoriale integrität aller
staaten also damit auch der ukraine
gewahrt bleibt auf der anderen seite
äußert er verständnis für die für das
russische anliegen der gleichen
sicherheit dass die sicherheit des einen
öffentlich auf kosten des anderen gegen
darf also die frage der nato erweiterung
wird hier angesprochen ich würde
das wichtigste ist glaube ich dass china
und russland unterschiedliche interessen
in dieser frage haben auch wenn sie
gerade eine gemeinsame erklärung wären
die olympischen spiele warten sie also
über gemeinsame interessen oder
unterschiedliche interessen können
gleich vielleicht weiterhin heumann
vielen dank bis hierhin denn wir können
uns gemeinsam liebe zuschauer jetzt mal
anschauen was denn der chinesische
außenminister gesagt hat hier kommt der
o-ton
die situation in der ukraine ist so
geworden wie sie heute ist weil es dafür
verschiedene komplexe gründe gibt für
die lösung komplexer probleme braucht
man einen kühlen kopf und einen klaren
geist man darf nicht öl ins feuer gießen
und die situation verschlimmern china
glaubt dass für die lösung der krise die
zwecke der und grundsätze der un charta
hoch gehalten werden müssen und die
souveränität und territoriale integrität
aller länder respektiert werden muss wir
müssen uns den prinzipien der
untrennbaren sicherheit verschreiben und
die legitimen sicherheitsinteressen der
beteiligten parteien respektieren wir
müssen auseinandersetzungen friedlich
beilegen durch dialog und verhandlungen
und wir müssen uns daran erinnern dass
für einen langfristigen frieden und
stabilität in der region eine
ausgewogene effektive und nachhaltige
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
etabliert werden muss
angesichts der lage muss die
internationale gemeinschaft weiterhin an
zwei prioritäten arbeiten eine priorität
ist die förderung des dialogs zum für
den frieden china hat in dieser hinsicht
bereits anstrengungen unternommen und
hat sich eng mit den involvierten
parteien ausgetauscht am zweiten tag des
konflikts hat präsident jean ping mit
präsident wladimir putin am telefon
gesprochen und betonte dass china sich
wünsche dass russland und die ukraine
friedensverhandlungen so früh wie
möglich führen präsident putin begrüßte
dies und russland und die ukraine
seitdem zwei gesprächsrunden geführt wir
hoffen dass die dritte runde die jetzt
ansteht zu weiteren fortschritten führen
wird china glaubt dass je mehr spannung
es gibt desto wichtiger ist es dass die
gespräche fortgeführt werden je weiter
die meinungen auseinandergehen letzte
wichtige es ist sich an einen tisch zu
setzen und zu verhandeln china möchte
eine konstruktive rolle spielen um den
dialog für den frieden zu fördern und
mit der internationalen gemeinschaft
zusammenarbeiten und eventuell auch als
mediator tätig werden andere prioritäten
sind eine humanitäre krise zu verwenden
abzuwenden hierfür schlägt china einen
sechs punkte plan vor erstens
sicherstellen dass die humanitären
einsätze neutral und unparteiisch
ablaufen und humanitäre fragen nicht
politisiert werden zweitens
die vertriebenen in der ukraine und
außerhalb der ukraine
unterstützen und ihnen schutz bieten
drittens die zivilgesellschaft
gesellschaft vor einer humanitären
katastrophe bewahren viertens die
aktivitäten der humanitären hilfe
sicherstellen einschließlich schneller
sicherer und ungehinderter zugänge
fünftens die sicherheit von
ausländischen mitbürgerinnen und bürgern
sicherstellen und ihnen helfen in ihre
heimatländer zurückzukehren
6 die unterstützung der koordinierenden
rolle der un bei der kanalisierung der
humanitären hilfe
auch im zusammenarbeit mit dem un
krisenkoordinator für die ukraine china
wird sich weiterhin damit darum bemüht
in dieser humanitären krise krise zu
unterstützen ich möchte ankündigen dass
das chinesische rote kreuz
der ukraine
notfall materialien in humanitärer hilfe
liefern wird die welt ist in der tat
alles andere als friedlich sehr starke
veränderungen vollziehen sich gerade
hier vor unseren augen ein großes land
in seinem harmonie streben
die mentalität des kalten krieges wieder
aufleben lassen dies hat so instabilität
und spaltung geführt und die welt noch
mehr belastet die sich bereits zu vielen
herausforderungen gegenüber sieht was
können wir tun china glaubt ganz fest
daran dass der richtige weg in einer
erhöhung der solidarität und
zusammenarbeit liegt im in der idee des
multi multilateralismus rund gemeinsamen
anstrengungen die gemeinsam der
menschheit dienen wie präsident jean
ping sagt ist es inmitten der
turbulenzen einer globalen krise wichtig
dass die länder nicht allein 190 kleinen
boten segeln sondern alle gemeinsam in
einem großen boot das gemeinsame
schicksal teilen kleine schiffe können
dem sturm nicht länger widerstehen aber
ein großes boot kann den sturm besiegen
der frieden hat die oberste priorität er
ist die basis und voraussetzung für
entwicklungen jeglicher art die länder
müssen der vision einer gemeinsamen
umfassenden und nachhaltigen sicherheit
folgen und die idee einer exklusiven und
absoluten sicherheit ablehnen konflikte
müssen durch verhandlungen gelöst werden
auseinandersetzungen durch den dialog
und das gegenseitige vertrauen muss
gestärkt werden so dass wir
zusammenarbeiten können um einen lang
anhaltenden frieden sicherstellen zu
können zweitens brauchen wir mehr
solidarität vielfalt ist hier besonders
wichtig unterschiede führen nicht
notwendigerweise zu konfrontationen
die länder müssen einen wahren
multilateralismus praktizieren und sich
auf gemeinsame werte stützen und
hegemonie und machtpolitik ablehnen wir
müssen sie das internationale system das
sich um die un zentriert hochhalten und
dies basiert auf den grundwerten der un
charta wir arbeiten dabei daran das
globale system der regierungsführung
gerechter zu machen
das war also der chinesische
außenminister heute in peking reumann
man muss jetzt nicht alles ernst nehmen
was der mann da erzählt vor allem wenn
es um machtpolitik geht die man
vielleicht lieber auf der un basis und
wenn überhaupt im uhrenbereich
besprechen so halte aber sie haben
gerade gesagt als der beitrag lief das
ist die nachricht des tages für sie
warum nur weil er eindeutig hat der
vermittler rolle chinas anbietet rang
der außenminister das war ja bisher
nicht klar da gab es ein lavieren
das ist die wichtigste aussage schon und
es schien als vermittler hätte auch
wahrscheinlich mehr gewicht als türkei
oder israel in dieser frage sie haben
richtig gesagt man muss nicht alles auf
die goldwaage legen bei solchen
äußerungen diesen englischen äußerungen
aber man muss trotzdem genau zuhören
weil er nämlich nicht nichts geringeres
gesagt hat als dass die territoriale
integrität
aller länder gewahrt werden muss damit
man dann natürlich auch die ukraine
übrigens ist mir aufgefallen seien sechs
punkte plan ist ein ist jetzt auf den
ersten blick ein humanitärer als der
decke zum militär ist also keine
strategischen fragen aber auch da ist
ein punkt dabei dass keine zivilen ziele
angegriffen werden also das was wir
gerade erleben also china bringt sich in
dieser position zwischen russland und
den westlichen ländern und möchte
vermitteln das interesse daran ist
natürlich auch hier eine gewisse
vielleicht auch globale führungsrolle zu
kommen aber ich möchte daran erinnern
was natürlich jetzt nicht in diese
äußerung herauskam dass russland und
china durchaus unterschied der
unterschiedliche interessen haben auch
was die weltordnung angeht auf der einen
seite klar china russland ist für china
einer der zusammen die multipolare
ordnung will dann gibt es noch
rüstungszusammenarbeit energie aber man
muss sich ganz klar sehen die sind nicht
auf augenhöhe
russland steigt ab china steigt auf und
das mal ganz kurz auszudrücken außerdem
und das ist vielleicht das
allerwichtigste und was china bewegt zu
diesem schritt china hat keinerlei
interesse
europa mit dem es handel treibt und als
haupthandelspartner hat als gegner zu
haben es hat auch kein interesse an den
sanktionen die
in gang gesetzt worden sind also hier
gibt es ein unterschiedliches kritisch
vorher haben wir darüber gesprochen was
ich jetzt wohl bestätigt hat das ist
möglicherweise am donnerstag gespräche
in der türkei geben wird ja bei den
außenminister der ukraine und russlands
es gibt ja wohl auch heute wieder
gespräche bilateral
wenn sie denn zustande kommen zwischen
der ukraine und russland
man muss glaube ich ja diese gespräche
nicht überbewerten denn derweil schafft
putin mit seinen truppen mit seinen
militärs brutalste fakten in der ukraine
oder ja ich glaube nicht dass punktiert
im augenblick an verhandlungen an
gesprächen wirklich interessiert ist
möchte nur nicht derjenige sein der die
ablehnt diese gespräche und wenn die
stadt gefunden haben haben sie über
humanitäre fragen stattgefunden über
humanitäre korridore und selbst das hat
ja nach zwei runden auch noch nicht
geklappt weil selbst diese frage der
korridore von russland missbraucht wird
um
die menschen die durch diese korridore
dann die stadt verlassen würden nach
russland zu lenken dass man ja die
russischen wusste was eine besonders
perfide idee ist ja also ich glaube wohl
sagen hat kein interesse im augenblick
verhandeln putin hält an seinen
maximalen zielen der totalen kontrolle
wie die ukraine fest und der des
regierungs weg zum endverbraucher
wer den krieg nicht in seinem sinn
verläuft mit den bekannten folgen die
jetzt zu besichtigen sind in furchtbaren
bildern aus der ukraine vielen dank bis
hierhin herr räumen liebe zuschauer wir
wollen uns gleich mit den finanziellen
und wirtschaftlichen im blick